دعا امير دوله قطر الشيخ تمي بن حمد ال
الثاني الجميع لدعم جهود تركيا في تجاوز
اثار الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا الشهر
الماضي واعرب امير دوله قطر في كلمته في
افتتاح المؤتمر الامم المتحده الخامس
المعنيه بالدول الاقل نموا المنعقد في
الدوحه عن استغرابه من تاخر تقديم
المساعدات لضحايا الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا
ينعدوا اجتماعنا واخواننا في تركيا وسوريا
ما زالوا يعانون من اثار كارثه الزلزال
الهائل التي اصابتهما وتضرر منها الملايين
واني من هنا اذ اؤكد باسمكم جميعا على
تضامنا مع الشقاء في تركيا وسوريا ادعو
الجميع لدعم جهود تركيا في تجاوز اثار هذه
الكارثه
واؤكد على ضروره مدى مد يد العون من دون
تردد للشعب السوري الشقيق
واستغربوا تاخر المساعدات في الوصول الى
هذا الشعب مؤكدا على عدم جواز استغلال
الماساه الانسانيه لاغراض سياسيه
واعلنا امير قطر خلال كلمته في افتتاح
مؤتمر الامم المتحده الخامس المعني بالدول
الاقل نموا عن تقديم مساهمه بقيمه 60
مليون دولار انطلاقا من التزام دوله قطر
الثابت تجاه دعم عمليه التنميه لاقل
البلدان نموا
وانطلاقا من التزام دوله قطر الثابت تجاه
دعم عمليه التنميه لاقل البلدان نموا
اعلنوا عن تقديم مساهمه ماليه باجمال ستين
مليون دولار امريكي يخصص منها 10 مليون
دولار لدعم تنفيذ انشطه برنامج عمل الدوحه
لصالح اقل البلدان نموا ويخصص مبلغ 50
مليون دولار لدعم نتائج المتوفى لبرنامج
عمل الدوحه وبناء القدرات على الصمود في
اقل البلدان نموا
وادعو الشركاء التنمويين بان يحذوا حذو
قطر ويبادر بدعم تنفيذ برنامج عمل الدوحه
كجزء من واجبنا الانسان والتنموي تجاه
الشعوب البلدان الاقل لنموا